what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
what's going on guys this is Robin
before we begin I want to let you guys
know this video is sponsored by my
beautiful hair and if you want to have
beautiful hair just like this make sure
you guys hit the subscribe button
because then you'll get more of my sexy
boys and my sexy voice gives you better
hair it's true or it's true it's 100%
true I know a lot of you guys don't
believe me but it is true
maestro Hulk and Professor Hulk I think
these are entirely possible like okay
here's here's a cool thing right here so
here's here's here's the whole reason
why I kind of get into this I was
looking at the comments section of the
world war hulk video that i did and a
lot of you guys were like made some
really really good points like a lot of
like a lot of really good points but one
of the best points that came out of that
was really fun like maybe four or five
of you guys and you said like it would
it wouldn't make a whole lot of sense to
bring back the character of Betty Ross
and the reason why is because would the
character of Betty Ross she was in the
first Incredible Hulk movie with Edward
Norton and then we basically haven't
seen her since and Marvel's really like
distanced themselves from that movie
there's been no reference to abomination
there's been no reference to like Betty
Ross herself there's been no reference
to any of that stuff even to the guy
Emil Blonsky you know just the things
that he did in order to become
abomination none of that exists as we
see neither hide nor hair of that the
only thing from The Incredible Hulk film
that was carried over was Thunderbolt
Ross and that makes sense because he's
such an intrinsic part of the Bruce
Banner Bruce Banner Incredible Hulk
mythos but then I would say so is Betty
Ross so what they're ready to make a
whole lot of sense to me to not really
bring Betty Ross over but a lot of you
guys said that's a really good point and
my whole idea of the Incredible Hulk
transitioning from his standard Hulk
form to world breaker or even harder the
monster Hulk was contingent on like the
death of Betty Ross because as we know
from Marvel Comics the reason why world
breaker Hulk came into existence why
hope was elevated to that level of anger
is because during the events of Planet
Hulk his wife and unborn child were
believed well his unborn child was
believed to have been dead and his wife
was was most definitely killed and so
because of that light it just pushed his
anger to new heights because what little
happiness he found had been yanked away
and we really know just from general
knowledge of the Incredible Hulk mythos
that his feelings for Betty Ross are
more significant than anybody else's one
of the other really good points that you
guys made was well maybe it'll be Black
Widow maybe
like widow will be the person who will
die that will lead to Bruce Banner
transitioning to to become world work or
Hulk but that's kind of the crazy thing
is the more I thought about that the
more I thought about what went down in
Avengers infinity war a little bit of a
spoiler here you know I mean movies been
out for a week and a half two weeks
it's the highest grossing Marvel movie
to date I'm pretty sure it is anyway it
is it's it's if you haven't seen it by
now then I don't know what to tell you
uh when it comes to like Bruce Banner in
and Black Widow I think the idea of them
having a romance was toyed with I think
the idea of having them you know engaged
in romance was interesting and it was
there but I don't think the feelings
that Bruce Banner has for black widow in
the MCU would be enough that if she died
he would just push to a new level of
anger so maybe world breaker hope just
doesn't exist like maybe that will never
happen but if it doesn't happen then
something will have to happen to the
Hulk and the reason why is because in in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe there has
never been a movie that involves the
Avengers ensemble or the involvement of
The Incredible Hulk
that does not see him have his moment
that doesn't really see him have like
just kind of pop off and everything goes
awry right like we saw that in the first
Avengers film you know like Bruce Banner
returns as The Incredible Hulk
and just kind of like ah you know the
personalities are kind of working in
unison The Incredible Hulk realizes hey
it's my job to protect the earth and
Bruce Banner wants to protect the earth
and so it's kind of a seamless
transition from one to the other for
Bruce Banner to let the incredible whole
persona come out as a result the entire
battle was shifted in favor of the
Avengers when the Incredible Hulk Iran
plus he also caught Iron Man and don't
even tell me you guys don't even tell me
well you guys saw the trailer for
Avengers and you're like dude the
Incredible Hulk catches Iron Man like
like don't tell me you weren't - you saw
I was I was like okay this movie's gonna
be balls amazing it's gonna be this
gonna be a maze balls is what its gonna
be
ah but then you also go into like
Avengers 2 and you have the Incredible
Hulk who fights the Thor but or fights
the the Hulkbuster armor and just like
rips it to shreds and then you have you
have four Ragnarok where you have for
fighting The Incredible Hulk
and and basically like The Incredible
Hulk wins he always comes out on top and
then you transition to infinity war and
that fight was a minute and a half long
and it was the Incredible Hulk getting a
couple blows in
then Thanos beating on him like a sign
of beef and The Incredible Hulk was too
scared to come out again so because of
the fact that infinity war and Avengers
4 are basically the same like the a
singular movie split into two halves it
makes sense that it follows a transition
of the Incredible Hulk in the sense that
he'll have this huge Hawk Down moment
and if that happens what version of The
Incredible Hulk are we gonna see and
that's when I kind of get into the idea
of like that's what I talked about world
break or Hulk and that kind of a thing
but in this video the idea of like
Professor Hulk or even maestro Hulk is
really really intriguing because I still
stick by the idea that just because
Thanos has the Infinity Gauntlet now
does not mean he's gonna have the
Infinity Gauntlet five years from now
and whether it's because somebody like
like whether it's because one of the
Avengers comes back or some superhero we
haven't seen before grabsy Infinity
Gauntlet from the future and comes back
the something's gonna have to give there
I wouldn't be surprised if you saw like
two Infinity gauntlets in the same story
and the reason why is because in Marvel
you've never seen that it's the one
thing for Marvel comics that you've
never seen is to infinity gauntlets in
the exact same story and we know from
the interview the Russo brothers have
done that this movie's supposed to like
break new ground and just kind of like
shatter or you know shatter these
different things that break away from
like the traditional comic book story
and tell a story that hasn't been told
before and how amazing would it be if
someone traveled back in time with the
Infinity Gauntlet from five years in the
future and then like fought the fight
against Thanos with the Infinity gaalan
in the modern day you know I have no
idea how that would work out no idea how
that would transpire but it would be
cool but with regards to the idea of
mystras first one I want to talk about I
wouldn't go as far as to say my shirt
would be the one to do it because it
wouldn't really be something maestro
would do just because of the way that
his characters is designed I would say
maestro assuming I mean my shirt
wouldn't stand a chance to get seen
against Thanos well going by the MCU
evidence
maybe I mean we don't know how powerful
the Infinity Gauntlet is if it's been
reduced in power by half I'd still say
maestro wouldn't win because even with
like the power of the Infinity Gauntlet
even cut in half you're talking about
the mind stone the time stone the
reality stone the space stone I mean the
abilities are just like like the soul
stone just like dominate the environment
around maestro even if it's not on a
universal scale and it's in a localized
space
the maestro probably wouldn't win there
but the maestro is a warlord so here's
the deal so maestro Hulk was a version
of The Incredible Hulk that originally
appeared prior to the events of future
imperfect and
one of the things a lot of people get
wrong I don't know her the exact issue
he appeared in he was a Peter David
creation but it was one of those things
where he was kind of alluded to and then
like you saw him a little bit but really
future imperfect is like the first story
that really features maestro hook and
it's really the story that kind of God
has claim to fame so at some point in
the future what you end up having is
this realm where really the the earth
has kind of been like devastated by a
nuclear destruction and the result is
that because the Incredible Hulk is
literally a walking gamma bomb he
basically started absorbing all of this
nuclear radiation and it made him a lot
stronger but it also sort of drove him a
little bit mad but what ended up doing
was basically consolidating the remnants
of humanity into a singular city and
then ruled that city with an iron fist
now what you had is you also had Rick
Jones who was the kind of sidekick of
the Incredible Hulk when he was younger
as friend and what-have-you
who was older in this future and then
basically brought the incredible hope
from the present day into the future and
the maestro beat the hell out of him it
was amazing do the maestro beat the
absolute tar out of the incredible [ __ ]
it was man it was amazing it was it was
one of the coolest fights what is it I
think I think he breaks his neck he
shatters his collarbone I mean he just
he like thrashes him it's it's it's
awesome because what Marvel established
with maestro Hulk is that he's basically
a version of the Hulk who is a whole lot
stronger and a lot smarter he's
basically a warlord like it's it's it's
one of the most badass things plus he
looks cool he's got like gray hair that
runs down and I think he's got like a
goatee or a mustache or what-have-you
he looks he looks pretty solid I would
love to see that version of The
Incredible Hulk from the future because
I mean seeing maestro Hulk against
Thanos with no Infinity Gauntlet
I think maestro would win if I'm being
honest like if I'm being 100% honest
with you guys
I really believe my stroke would
probably win maybe he wouldn't but like
I I think in the MCU like if yeah I
think maestro hope he'll be able to pull
it off because he's super smart he's a
cunning strategist he's wildly capable
and he's just like insanely strong so I
think he'd be able to take on Thanos um
but then you're getting a like Professor
Hawk so here's the deal so what happened
in Marvel Comics is is the Incredible
Hulk after the writing of Stan Lee and
Jack Kirby was okay and it was just a
line of comics that were there but in
truth model was exploding so rapidly in
the 1960s that like everything was
selling it didn't really matter what it
was if it had marvel's name on it aside
like really really really bad stories
like the original x-men pretty much
everything sold and so what you ended up
having was the Incredible Hulk who was
taken over by a guy named bill Mantlo
and bill Mantlo changed the whole
dynamic of the whole this is where you
start to get into the idea that the
incredible that Bruce Banner himself was
a victim of a very abusive father and so
the Incredible Hulk was just kind of a
manifestation of all this anger and rage
that Bruce Banner kept inside of him
there was really no form for all this
anger and all this all this pent-up
aggression and things like that until
Bruce Banner was hit with a gamma bomb
and then it all manifested in the form
of the Incredible Hulk and that's what
the whole is when bill Mantlo wrote it
now bill batlem eventually left and then
a guy named Peter David took over and
Peter David did a lot of things to
expand the Hulk but his run was really
predicated on what Mantlo had done and
so that's when he was sort of getting
into things like the idea of like
nightmare Hulk you know this this notion
of like dark Hulk devil hulk things like
that these versions of The Incredible
Hulk that represented tormented aspects
of his life some of them even reveries
like one of them to represent it as dad
and so it was it was cool when he got
into that whole thing but in that story
what ended up happening is Bruce Banner
came to this realization that all these
different versions of the Hopi exist out
there because he's essentially
manifested them and so what he did is he
basically merged the grey Hulk and the
green Hulk together into a singular
person really into himself and then we
got the professor well it wasn't
originally the professor originally back
in the Incredible Hulk vol 1 377 it was
just merged whole that's really all it
was called ah but at the time it was the
most powerful version of The Incredible
Hulk that existed because what it was is
it was Bruce banners ideal perception of
himself it was like Bruce Banner sitting
down and saying if I wanted to be the
Incredible Hulk and if I had total
control over the Incredible Hulk
you know over all the powers he
possesses his healing factors so on and
so forth his unlimited strength if I had
total control over all those things what
would I be like and that's merged Hulk
the professor was a name that was given
later on down the line because it's
basically all the powers of the
Incredible Hulk with a brain of Bruce
Banner it's pretty badass oh he was he
was he was pretty solid in that regard I
could see either one of those really
kind of coming out here and the reason
why is is I think Professor Hulk is
probably more reasonable than maestro
maestro is really more just me fanboying
it's really more just like a wish that I
would love to see there's really no
reason to believe
what happened and in fact it is pretty
far-fetched to make an argument that
maestro would show up because he'd have
to explain the whole idea of the maestro
where he comes from
why he believes what he does why he does
the kind of things he does how dangerous
is he how strong is he
he'd have to explain all those different
things but with Professor Hulk it's a
whole lot easier
professor Hulk I mean we haven't seen
great Hulk we haven't seen like Joe fix
it right for those who guys who don't
know when the Incredible Hulk was
originally created in Marvel Comics
he was gray and the problem was that
Marvel couldn't keep the color scheme
going and so what they did is they made
him green instead and so later on Marvel
came back and wrecked condit and said
actually that original grey version was
a version called Joe fix it and then the
green version popped up as savage Hulk
who you've been reading about ever since
you just hadn't seen that version Joe
fix it until now and that many finally
makes his return
Joe fix it was pretty cool he wasn't as
powerful as the other hoax but he was
pretty cool he was actually like a a
bouncer in Las Vegas I think it was
which is kind of funny to see him like
do was do his whole thing
Joe fix it was kind of cool it depends
on who writes him really um he has his
fans you know it's it's it's however you
want to go with it I believe we've done
we've covered the story that had yo fix
it I'm pretty sure we did that as part
of like the whole Greg Pak run on the
Incredible Hulk but the fact remains
here when it comes to the idea because
we don't really have great Hulk well you
could literally do is you could have the
aftermath your massive infinity war I
need to basically say like like Bruce
Banner sits down and has like a
heart-to-heart conversation with the
Incredible Hulk and the incredible hopes
like I'm you know at like I'm scared
like I'm really scared I've never faced
anyone likes a nose before I've never
fought a being of such immense strength
that he overpowered me in less than a
minute and crushed me whole handedly
like I've never faced a force like that
before you know and it would make sense
of the Incredible Hulk is felt fear
because unlike the Marvel comics were
side the Incredible Hulk just keeps
getting angrier and angrier and angrier
and that's it the MCU has added a lot of
personality to the Incredible Hulk so
he's very much his own person which he's
designed to be a wholly separate
personality from Bruce Banner and so
when you're talking about this version
of the Incredible Hulk
that has his own personality the feels
love feels anger wants to be left alone
wants to be left in peace has people
that he cares about all those different
things it makes sense that you can in
turn add the emotion of fear and say the
incredible
just scared but then you have the point
where it kind of switches dichotomies
right like Bruce Banner supposed to be
the scared one Bruce Banner supposed to
be the coward he's supposed to be the
one running from the fight as opposed to
running into the fight but then you get
into infinity war and it's a totally
different dynamic Bruce you know like
the incredible Hawks like I'm scared I
really don't want to fight I don't want
to be here you know I don't wanna have
any part of this and then Bruce Banner
is like well then fine I'll take care of
it and so what you could do is have this
kind of conversation between the two
where Bruce Banner is like look man
you've got to toughen up but I think I
know how we can win we can just become
one person like we can just merge into a
single person instead of me turning into
you you know turning into you the
Incredible Hulk
and you the Incredible Hulk turning into
me Bruce Banner we can just be one
singular person you know you give me all
your powers and all your strength let me
let me basically run the show and like
we can win this and so it allows the
Incredible Hulk to be part of the fight
without actually being part of the fight
that's the only way I could really
imagine professor Hulk being involved
here but again that's a far fetch I mean
I have no idea what direction they're
gonna go in for the hope it could just
be that the incredible hopes like yeah
man I'm tough now all right cool let's
do this so then he just jumps back into
the fight you know and would probably
get rekt like everybody else I have no
clue I mean I'm I'm really just kind of
curious in terms of how these things are
gonna go um yeah it's it's wild like
it's it's really really wild and it's
really fun to talk about these kind of
things I love making these videos and
you guys apparently love watching them
and I'll keep making them as long as you
guys watch them so that's kind of how
that goes but we're not being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
and make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the robb core
if you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and that will catch you
all later peace
[Music]
[Music]